We have a real and true national security
red alert here to discuss.
And it comes down to fundamentally pushing
through the last possible stand of keeping
some things sacred in the sense of keeping
it outside of the reach of political machinations
or matching nations, as some like to say,
which is that Donald Trump's intelligence
officials are no longer going to be briefing
Democrats with a question mark as to whether
they will be briefing Joe Biden as the nominee
of the Democratic Party for president.
And House member Adam Schiff has sounded the
alarm on this over the weekend.
He said that his committee may end up having
to subpoena intelligence officials because
John Ratcliffe, who's the director of national
intelligence, announced that regular election
security briefings were going to be scaled
back ahead of the general election instead
of actually briefing members of the Democratic
Party.
They are going to give them some written documents,
which, of course, provides no opportunity
to ask questions.
Now, this is not only obviously political.
But it is also obviously related to upcoming
election interference that the Trump administration
itself doesn't have an interest in stopping.
Why?
Because on balance, it's expected to be beneficial
to him.
So here is Donald Trump being asked about
this recently.
He says the reason his leaks, leaks, leaks,
Adam Schiff and whoever they would brief would
just leak the information.
Take a look.
Whether we're Shifty Schiff or somebody else,
they leaked the information before it gets
in.
And what's even worse, a leak, the wrong information.
And he got tired of it.
So he wants to do it in a different forum
because you have leakers on the committee.
Obviously, leakers that are doing bad things,
probably not even illegal to leak.
But we'll look into that separately.
But they were leaking the information as brought
in.
And how would you.
You don't have that in Texas.
Can you wouldn't allow that in Texas.
I guarantee you Ken will not be allowing the
leakers to be doing that.
So we were.
He wanted to make sure that it does.
Italy Karplus.
So this is a lie that this is just not true.
The real reason why the Trump administration
has directed the intelligence community to
stop briefing Democrats, as reported by Politico,
is that classified security briefings were
given to members of Congress and in those
briefings.
William ever.
Nina, who who's the direction director of
the National Counterintelligence and Security
Center, said Russia is trying to help Trump
win.
Russia is trying to denigrate Joe Biden in
order to help Donald Trump will win.
So what is the Trump administration?
Do they say stop telling Democrats that that's
what's going on?
You might remember, and this is why this is
so important.
I mean, we don't have to theorize about the
implications of this.
Think back to 2016 when Barack Obama was president
and Donald Trump was the challenger, the Republican
nominee, Barack Obama's intelligence officials.
As is tradition as should be, the case briefed
Barack Obama and Donald Trump about Russia's
interests in helping Donald Trump to win about
the Steele dossier and the information contained
within it.
And if you think back to that and you consider
the importance of these briefings, you then
very quickly realize the only real reason
that Donald Trump would have to say stop briefing
Democrats is he doesn't want them to know
what is in those security briefings because
it is not particularly good for Donald Trump
for that information to be known.
And what we know, what William F. Anina was
saying has been reported otherwise, which
is, yeah, Russia prefers Donald Trump.
Period.
Now, many will write to me and say, but, David,
China prefers Biden and Iran prefers Biden.
OK, yeah, we I've told you that we've discussed
that, that that I'm not denying that.
And there are geopolitical reasons for all
of the preferences that other countries have.
But Donald Trump is specifically trying to
prevent one perspective from getting out there,
and that is that once again, Russia has an
interest in helping Donald Trump win.
So these people need to be held accountable.
Step one for accountability is November 3rd.
That's the most pressing one.
It's September now.
We are two months.
We are just weeks essentially from this election.
Votes are going to start being cast in some
places.
I think it's within 10 days, some states will
start early voting.
So step one for holding accountable is removing
Donald Trump.
Then we are going to have to see where the
chips fall and who is involved in wrongdoing.
And while there is, I believe, no real possibility
that Donald Trump is charged with anything
once he's no longer president, I know that
there's people dreaming of Trump in handcuffs.
That's not what the U.S. does to former presidents.
It's not my opinion.
It's just the reality.
That doesn't mean that there aren't other
people.
Could it be Dungeon Junior?
Could it be Jared Kushner?
Could it be people whose names maybe we don't
know who should and could be held accountable
and we're going to have to see.
They're not even trying to hide it.
There's foreign meddling again.
And Trump's interference is in getting in
the way of people learning about what Russia
is doing.
Consider that.
And by the way, just look back at the last
four years of getting in the way of any serious
attempts to actually stop foreign meddling.
Why would he try to stop it?
It's useful
to him.